La majorité de ce que l'on voit
pousser dans les champs sont des
cultures annuelles : le maïs, le
soya, des céréales comme le blé.
Et les plantes pérennes, celles
qui survivent pendant plusieurs
années, n'ont plus la cote.
On n'a qu'à penser à toutes
les plantes qui composent le
foin qu'on donne aux animaux,
comme la luzerne par exemple.
Pourtant, ces cultures sont
d'excellentes alliées pour
améliorer la santé du sol,
et leur demande est en forte
croissance.
♪ ♪ ♪
- (narratrice): Dans les champs
de la Ferme Valbois, en Estrie,
la première coupe de foin
est réglée au quart de tour.
Faucheuse, faneuse, râteau
vont et viennent sans relâche.
Avec près de 1000 hectares de
plantes fourragères en culture,
il y a encore beaucoup
de travail à faire.
Le foin est jeune, très
feuillu et d'un beau vert.
Ici, aucun signe de sécheresse.
- Le foin est beau, est de
qualité, il est fourni. On est
très heureux pour l'instant,
là. Ça s'enligne bien pour
le reste de la saison.
- À la Ferme Valbois, le foin
est récolté très tôt en saison.
La quantité de balles produite
est donc un peu moins
importante. Mais ce foin
«primeur», sans déchets
ni additifs, est recherché
par les clients.
- Nous, ça s'en va tout aux
États-Unis. On sait qu'aux
États-Unis, il y a des chevaux
à plusieurs millions de dollars.
Les producteurs sont très fiers
de leurs animaux. Ça s'en
va tout là : Boston, Floride,
Miami; tout dans ce coin-là.
♪ ♪ ♪
- À 120 km de Coaticook,
dans ce champ de la Montérégie,
la première coupe de foin
s'annonce plus décevante.
- À la date où on est, le foin
devrait nous venir presque aux
épaules et j'ai de la misère
à l'avoir aux genoux.
Ça s'annonce une récolte
très moyenne pour cette année.
- Depuis trois ans, la culture
des plantes fourragères est
laborieuse pour Luc Normandin,
l'un des plus importants
commerçants de foin au Québec :
manque de couvert de neige, gel
et mortalité en hiver, chaleur
et sécheresse l'été. La météo
fait des siennes. Loin de se
décourager, Luc Normandin y
voit plutôt une opportunité.
- Comme commerçant de foin,
c'est une opportunité parce
qu'il va y avoir plein de
gens qui vont manquer de foin.
- Pour garnir ses immenses
entrepôts, il compte sur tout un
réseau de producteurs de plantes
fourragères à travers le pays.
En diversifiant les emplacements
de production, Luc Normandin
s'assure de pouvoir répondre
aux besoins de ses clients
en Europe, au Moyen-Orient
et aux États-Unis.
- On a des contacts un peu
partout dans toutes les
provinces pour acheter du foin
aux endroits où ils ont
des bonnes conditions pour
le produire et qui veulent
nous le vendre.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Valérie Poulin et Luc
Normandin, deux anciens
producteurs de lait convertis
à la culture des plantes
fourragères, ont bâti
des entreprises de commerce
de foin prospères.
- On est un peu comme Astérix
et Obélix ici. Personne fait
de foin, donc on passe pour
fous, mais on est le royaume
pour le vendre.
- Au Québec, la culture du foin
est la plus grande en importance
en termes de superficie. Mais
les superficies qui lui sont
consacrées sont en baisse depuis
les années 80; une diminution
d'environ 25 %. Pourquoi?
D'abord, parce que le cheptel
laitier et le nombre de
producteurs laitiers et de
vaches de boucherie ont diminué.
Les producteurs agricoles
se sont aussi tournés vers
des cultures plus simples et
lucratives, comme le maïs et
le soya. Si bien qu'aujourd'hui,
le foin à vendre est souvent
un surplus produit à la ferme
dont la qualité laisse à
désirer. Mais cultiver le foin
pour en faire le commerce
demande beaucoup de travail,
à commencer par l'analyse des
sols. Cela permet de fertiliser
adéquatement les plantes
fourragères.
- Les analyses de sols sont
primordiales. La chaux,
l'engrais, c'est vraiment...
c'est très, très important.
C'est comme nourrir un humain
juste avec de l'eau :
c'est sûr qu'il va dépérir.
- Il faut aussi savoir naviguer
à travers les extrêmes
climatiques, avoir l'oeil
sur les radars météo.
Car l'élément-clé dans
le commerce du foin, c'est
un foin sec. Pour les marchés
d'exportation, le taux
d'humidité doit être de 12 %
ou moins. Difficile au Québec
de faire sécher le foin au
champ. Et si la récolte est
trop humide, le foin risque
de surchauffer ou de moisir.
- On a réussi à trouver une
façon de sécher le foin. C'est
ce qui nous a démarqués, c'est
ce qui nous démarque encore.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Luc Normandin a inventé
son propre modèle de séchoir.
Une fournaise à granules produit
de la chaleur; la chaleur et
l'air sont poussés vers le faux
plancher d'une remorque de
camion et circulent à travers le
foin entreposé dans la remorque.
En 24 à 36 heures, le foin
atteint le taux d'humidité
optimal.
Les propriétaires de la Ferme
Valbois ont investi eux aussi
dans un séchoir et un parc
de machineries spécialisées.
- On est rendus avec des
accumulateurs, on est rendus
avec des grappins, on est rendus
avec un plateau pour charger
les vans. Donc, t'sais, il faut
s'adapter. C'est la technologie.
Comme les cellulaires qui
changent aux années, bien,
la technologie dans le foin
évolue constamment aussi, là.
- Question d'optimiser
le transport à l'étranger
et d'augmenter la densité
des balles de foin, Norfoin
s'est doté d'un système
de transformation.
- Donc on s'est acheté de
l'équipement pour être capable
de compresser le foin puis de
vendre partout dans le monde.
Puis à travers le monde,
la demande est forte,
ça fait que c'est facile
de vendre du beau foin.
- La culture des plantes
fourragères et pérennes vient
donc avec son lot de défis.
Mais elle comporte aussi
d'énormes avantages sur
le plan environnemental.
- Les plantes fourragères,
comme je dis régulièrement,
elles sont généreuses parce
qu'elles ont amélioré la
structure des sols, elles ont
aussi apporté... emmagasiné
des éléments fertilisants, elles
ont créé des pores pour que le
système racinaire aille plus
profondément. On va aussi, avec
ces racines-là qui sont sur
du très long terme, augmenter
le niveau de carbone, de matière
organique dans le sol.
- Et puisqu'elles couvrent
le sol 365 jours par année,
les plantes pérennes limitent
l'érosion des sols. Malgré tout
ce potentiel, les producteurs
agricoles ont des réticences
à les intégrer dans leurs
cultures.
- Oui, il y a peut-être un
petit peu plus de défis quand
la sécheresse est présente,
mais on a d'autres alternatives,
je dirais. On a d'autres
possibilités. Faire des semis
plus à l'automne pour mieux
réussir nos implantations,
ça, c'est dans les choses
qu'on est en train de regarder.
On a des nouveaux cultivars
qui vont aussi être disponibles
dans pas grand temps.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Annie Classens fait justement
partie d'un petit groupe de
chercheurs qui développent
de nouveaux cultivars, plus
performants et mieux adaptés
aux extrêmes climatiques.
- Ce qu'on essaie de faire,
c'est surtout au niveau de la
fléole, des graminées, qui sont
plus sensibles à la sécheresse.
Donc ce qu'on essaie de faire,
c'est briser leur dormance
qui est causée par les hautes
températures.
- À la ferme expérimentale de
Saint-Augustin-de-Desmaures,
elle planche aussi sur
l'amélioration génétique
de la luzerne.
- On essaie d'augmenter la
tolérance au froid, la tolérance
aussi aux maladies printanières,
surtout les maladies racinaires.
Avec les changements climatiques
qui sont déjà arrivés, on a
des printemps très pluvieux,
très humides, donc les maladies
racinaires sont de plus
en plus présentes.
- L'amélioration génétique
des plantes fourragères est
un processus de pollinisation
croisée qui nécessite de 10 à
20 ans d'efforts. Dans cette
parcelle expérimentale, où
on essaie d'augmenter la saison
de croissance de la luzerne, les
résultats sont encourageants.
- Donc, on peut voir ici
des plants qui sont morts,
de la 70, la population de base,
comparativement à la population
améliorée où il y a quasiment
pas de mortalité.
- Donc ça, pour vous,
c'est une belle réussite?
- Ça, c'est très prometteur
pour moi, oui!
- D'autant plus prometteur que
les plantes fourragères sont
adaptées aux régions nordiques
et pourraient valoriser
des terres en friche.
- Ça va nous permettre d'avoir
une banque de fourrage qui va
pouvoir pallier ces manques-là
dans les différentes régions.
♪ ♪ ♪
- De nouvelles variétés de
plantes pérennes apparaissent
aussi dans les champs depuis
quelques années. Comme cette
graminée qui fait près de 2 m
de haut : le panic érigé.
L'entreprise Downey Tree,
spécialisée dans les sapins
de Noël, s'est lancée
dans l'aventure en 2013
et compte aujourd'hui 50 ha
de panic érigé.
- C'est une bonne rotation
dans nos champs de sapins.
En regardant le champ puis
la biodiversité que ça crée,
comme... ça, on est très
contents. Et en plus, on a
l'avantage d'avoir moins de
mauvaises herbes dans le champ.
On utilise moins de produits
chimiques. Donc c'est beaucoup
d'avantages pour nous.
On est très contents avec.
- Le paillis de panic érigé est
utilisé comme couvre-sol dans
la pépinière de sapins. Il est
moins acide et moins coûteux que
le paillis de cèdre traditionnel
et réduit les besoins en
irrigation. Il est aussi
vendu comme litière pour les
porcheries, servi dans la ration
des vaches laitières ou employé
en production maraîchère.
Bref, les vertus des plantes
pérennes et fourragères
sont largement documentées.
La demande est grande.
Les prix sont intéressants.
- C'est pas assez pour
convaincre les gens
de produire du foin.
- La culture du foin, qui a
contribué à façonner le paysage
rural du Québec, a un grand
potentiel, mais le développement
de la filière se fait attendre.